what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're going to answer the
question what would happen if Galactus
just like showed up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the reason why I say
that is because of course this story is
called cataclysm and this is a story
that basically took place after the
events of the original Age of Ultron
event where basically Wolverine broke
time and Galactus was teleported to the
Ultimate Universe now the reason why I
say the MCU is because the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is largely based off
the Ultimate Universe in Marvel Comics
because the Ultimate Universe was
designed to be a more realistic
depiction of the main Marvel Universe in
Marvel right like superheroes and so on
and so forth and so what you have here
in a really really cool set of
circumstances you basically have a
character that comes from the main
Marvel Universe where literally things
just happen because the plot demands
them whereas in the Ultimate Universe
things are more realistic so a just
ridiculously overpowered character in a
universe of what's basically
underpowered superheroes and so when
Galactus shows up here technically it's
Miles Morales who's one of the first
people to realize he's there what's
funny about this is that he teleports
away and and then he comes back and so
once galatas officially appears on the
scene in the story miles is the first
one to see this now miles has no idea
how to handle this situation and he even
goes so far as to ask the question like
what would Peter Parker do now one of
the things to remember is that in the
Ultimate Universe by the time Maya's
Morales comes onto the scene as
Spider-Man Peter Parker is basically
dead now there is a point where Miles
meets Peter and we'll talk more about
that over the course of the story
because they do reference that event and
in fact that storyline called Spider-Man
is actually Paramount to sort of
understanding how this story ends the
way that it does so I'll make sense of
it all but in what's debated as being or
really debated among fans as being a
true Galactus moment Galactus just
obliterates pretty much New Jersey uh
now of course people in New York don't
mind because it's New Jersey right it's
the poor man's New York but a lot of
people debate whether or not this is
truly a Galactus moment because when
Galactus shows up onto the scene in
Marvel Comics and like especially when
he shows up on Earth he doesn't just
arbitrarily obliterate an entire city
now this doesn't really happen if
anything he wouldn't care enough to
right he shows up he basically
constructs his world consuming machine
and that's effectively it and so what he
does here at least what ends up
happening here is the ultimate's respond
led by director Chang now technically
director Chang has replaced Nick Fury as
the Director of Shield she's not overly
important here so we don't really need
to go into the details of it if we end
up covering more stuff from the Ultimate
Universe we'll definitely talk about
that but the the really important thing
here is the ultimates so the ultimates
are basically the Ultimate Universe
version of The Avengers and in fact the
ultimates are what the Avengers in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are based off
of but the important thing here is that
with the ultimate showing up here they
don't really know how to respond to this
and in fact Shield initially just starts
launching an attack against Galactus and
hitting him with seemingly everything
they have now of course with all the
collateral damage and all the chaos and
the pandemonium and everything Miles
Morales steps in and tries to save
people where he can when he can but
Galactus being here is just something
crazy because Shield responds and asking
the question like where are the
ultimates and that's when the ultimate
arrive on the scene basically a
combination of the Fantastic Four and
the Ultimate Avengers now over the
course of this we are going to have a
conversation about the nature of
ultimate Fantastic Four because it's
really really cool and I'm really kind
of hoping they do this in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with the when the
Fantastic Four are introduced but
basically Iron Man Of course jumps in he
attacks Galactus the rest of the
ultimates jump in they attack Galactus
as best they can but nothing really
comes out of this and none of it really
matters they can't really do anything to
this guy I mean they kind of distract
him a little bit but this is par for the
course more so than that what they start
to realize here is Iron Man is analyzing
everything he basically scans Galactus
energy signature and what he realizes
here is that Galactus is not from this
earth now there's a way in which Tony
Stark figures this out right initially
if you're not aware of the events that
led into cataclysm your knee-jerk
reaction is that this is just Brian
Michael Bend is pulling a plot device
out of his backside to be able to write
the story but there was actually a set
of events right the Spider-Man story
that led to them realizing that there
are other universes outside their own
and that Galactus comes from one of
these universes so again we'll talk
about that here in a little bit but the
bigger question is if Galactus isn't
from this universe and what in the world
is he doing here they don't know how he
got there because they're unaware of the
events of Age of Ultron when the
question is asked from Tony Stark if
he's not here what does he want from us
the response to Stark is I think he
wants everything and what Galactus
starts doing is can is basically
constructing his world-consuming machine
now for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with the nature of Galactus as
this guy travels throughout the cosmos
traditionally in the main Marvel
Universe when he shows up to a world he
usually has his ship relatively close in
tow right tattoo but when Galactus shows
up to consume whether he's led to a
world by like the Silver Surfer or he
arrives at the world on his own then he
starts constructing a device that allows
him to tap into the core energies of a
planet absorb those core energies and
the worlds usually destroyed in the
process but one of the things that
happens and really in kind of a bold
move Miles Morales literally attaches a
piece of webbing to a helicopter and
actually swings up to where Galactus is
at with the intention of communicating
with him now a lot of this is because
miles doesn't understand the nature of
Galactus Galactus isn't going to listen
to him he doesn't really care right and
so where Miles initially tries to
communicate with Galactus he's basically
Saved By The Avengers right in the
Avengers or I guess the ultimates end up
whisking him away which they consider it
kind of a ballsy decision for him to
make to try to even communicate with
this entity at all the other part of
this is that Tony Stark literally in the
shield Helicarrier at this point tells
all the ultimates and really all the
forces of Shield to stand down and when
they asked the question why he says
because scanning the nature of Galactus
that he feeds on energy so by attacking
this guy with bombs and arms and
Armament and even considering the
nuclear option all we're going to do is
feed this guy right he's just going to
absorb all the energy and then it's just
gonna make him stronger so it's
fruitless for us to attempt to do that
now the cool thing about this is that
with Tony Stark realizing that Galactus
comes from what we would basically call
the main Marvel universe or earth616
that the questions asked if he comes
from that universe is there anybody from
that Universe we can contact and the
response to Tony Stark is yes and what
he does is he goes to visit Mysterio now
this is where we have to talk about
Spider-Man so Spider-Man was a story
that was written in Marvel Comics that
was basically a follow-up to the death
of Peter Parker in the Ultimate Universe
right the Ultimate Universe Comics
launch in the year 2000 it really kicks
off with Ultimate Spider-Man and we get
an alternate reality version of Peter
Parker people loved him his stories were
really really cool and then we get to a
story where Peter Parker dies Ultimate
Universe Spider-Man is killed off and
Brian Michael Bendis and Marvel replace
him with Miles Morales people were
initially pissed off they hated Miles
Morales they love him now the people
hated Miles Morales and so what ended up
happening is Bendis wrote a story called
Spider-Man where Miles Morales
Spider-Man in The Ultimate Universe
meets Peter Parker in the main Marvel
Universe and Peter Parker in realizing
his alternate reality counterpart died
and that Miles has taken his place and
realizing the nature of miles in the
sense that he's a good guy he's doing
the best he can that he's not really
disrespecting the legacy of Peter or
anything like that earth616 Peter Parker
gives ultimate miles his Blessing to
continue operating as Spider-Man it was
basically venice's way of telling all
the Miles Morales detractors go screw
yourselves miles isn't going anywhere
you can learn to love him or you can
keep on hating him but that's a you
problem not an us Marvel problem which
he was right right like Miles Morales
stuck around and people love him now
right like for the most part people love
miles but the thing about this is that
in the Spider-Man story when this
crossover initially happened Mysterio
from the main Marvel Universe crossed
over into the Ultimate Universe and so
that version of Mysterio has basically
been here and been held prisoner ever
since so when Tony Stark shows up to
Quentin and literally says do you
recognize this person Quentin realizes
it's Galactus and what he tells him is
there's only one person in my universe
that Galactus would ever really listen
to and I'm aware that he exists here but
that person is Reed Richards now when
when Quentin Beck says this right when
Mysterio says you guys need to go find
your version of read because he
seemingly the only one that Galactus
will listen to nobody wants to do it
nobody wants to go talk to read or have
anything to do with it in fact when that
Revelation is given to the ultimates by
by Mysteria literally Tony Stark's
reaction is like did Reed Richards do
this I'll kill him I swear on my father
I will kill this guy and the funny thing
here is that Mysterio responds that he
says I love that you have so much
respect for me that you think this giant
guy is is in my pay grade and he says
from what I remember if it wasn't for
Reed Richards the one from my Earth
Galactus would have eaten us long ago
and so that's when Stark asks so your
read Richards created this or read
Richards saved you from this and the
response of Mysterio is like created no
this is read Richard's man the leader of
the Fantastic Four he's like the most
popular genius guy of all time hey I
even like him and I don't like anybody
he's always saving us from crazy stuff
like this do you guys have a Reed
Richards of your own and so the reason
why Tony Stark has such a visceral
reaction to the name of Reed Richards
and the reason why seemingly everybody
else does as well is because in the
Ultimate Universe Reed Richards became
the maker right in the main Marvel
Universe Earth 616 in Marvel Comics Reed
Richards is a scientific genius him and
a handful of friends basically stole a
ship they flew into space they got
bombarded by cosmic rays they crash
landed on Earth and they became the
Fantastic Fork Reed Richard's
intelligence in the main Marvel Universe
Earth 616 is respected universally right
almost every single race in the universe
if they're intelligent enough
understands and respects the
intelligence of Reed and so in in the
ultimate universe that was not the case
in the Ultimate Universe yes Reed
Richards was incredibly intelligent but
he became a villain and he's tried to
destroy the world more than once and so
that's why people hate that version of
read they despise that version of read
they don't want to have anything to do
with him but at the end of the day there
is no real option here and so what ends
up happening is they say okay fine then
if we don't want to have anything to do
with our read then we need to go to the
main Marvel Universe and get their read
right now initially Miles Morales offers
himself up as somebody who can travel to
the universe and visit read because he
knows Peter Parker right so all he'd
have to do is show up there find Peter
Parker and then when he sees Peter have
Peter take him to read Richards now the
funny thing about this is there's
another other story going on in the main
Marvel Universe at this point in time so
like miles will meet Peter Parker but it
won't be the Peter Parker that he knows
and those are the guys who are familiar
with the Spider-Man Mythos you know
exactly what I'm talking about right you
know exactly what I'm saying it was a it
was this is why cataclysm if you are
reading all of Marvel Comics at the time
it was a great story but the thing about
this is that while miles says look I
will go through this portal and I will
find their version of read that ultimate
read shows up seemingly out of nowhere
and agrees to go with miles now again
everybody hates him because he's just a
straight up villain he's a bad guy
having tried to destroy the world a
couple times and so ultimately they
realize though they need Reed but as
much as they hate him as much as they
despise him as crappy of a person as he
is they need Reed Richards they need
their ultimate read to travel to the
universe and speak to the main Marvel
Universe Reed Richards and so what ends
up happening is the portal is
effectively opened and both miles and
Reed end up passing through the problem
is that they all start to realize time
is of the essence because while they're
doing this Goliath is constructing his
world-consuming engine and so it's only
a matter of time before he starts to
consume the entirety of the world as it
exists and so as miles and Reed pass
through the portal and they end up in
the main Marvel Universe it actually
kind of takes them by surprise miles has
never been to the main Marvel Universe
before but when both he and ultimate
Reed get here they're kind of
flabbergasted by just how amazing the
world is it is actually a fairly
tranquil world all things considered now
of course the other part of this is that
this leads to Miles and ultimate read
infiltrating the Baxter building and
then literally because the Fantastic
Four are basically off Planet they start
making their way through the facility
trying to find some weapon or some
documentation something they can use to
grant them information on Galactus now
they end up discovering just the
gigantic computer system of Reed
Richards but the way that ultimate read
is granted access is that he's an
alternate reality counterpart to read
and there aren't really any safeguards
in place to protect the computer systems
of the main Marvel Universe read
Richards from an alternate reality
version of an self and so as they start
making their way to the system and as
they start looking up information about
Galactus they start to realize just how
dangerous this guy is the galatis goes
from one world to the next throughout
the entirety of the universe and just
consumes them and destroys them that
this version of Reed was able to fight
off Galactus using the ultimate
nullifier but the nullifier assuming
they simply just don't have they don't
have access to and so while they're in
this facility Valeria Richards shows up
now the now the exchange here between
Valeria and Reed is really really cool
because once Valeria sees his face she's
like you're not my father and it's like
miles is like wait a minute it's not
what you think it is and she says
Valeria Richards security protocol
override code word Franklin is a tool
and the entire facility locks down but
just before it does read hands all the
information to Miles and says get out of
here run and don't turn back and so as
miles makes his way out of the facility
which is now sending out all these
little drones to basically destroy him
he comes across Spider-Man and where he
initially thinks it's Peter Parker while
we don't get a great big huge exchange
between the two this is not Peter this
is superior Spider-Man so for those guys
guys who are unfamiliar with that and we
do have that down in the description
where you can kind of go over the
entirety of the Dan slot Spider-Man run
which includes this superior Spider-Man
was a story where Dr Octopus switched
bodies with Peter Parker and then he
became the new Spider-Man and Peter
Parker was stuck in the dying body of
Doc Ock it's a phenomenal Spider-Man
story I love it I think it's one of the
greatest Spider-Man stories ever written
by Marvel but once miles makes his way
back to the Ultimate Universe by passing
through the portal Reed Richards returns
as well and seeing the main Marvel
Universe and realizing what the Ultimate
Universe could be it almost kind of
leads Reed to abandon his villainous
ways and to come back to being a hero
but the bigger threat here is the threat
that Galactus poses right the idea of
Galactus consuming the entirety of their
world and so what this does is it
switches over to the ultimate X-Men who
are responding and helping where they
can when they can technically there is
an ultimate X-Men tie into the cataclysm
storyline it's for the most part
pointless literally they just kind of
sit around trying to figure out what to
do until like the third issue when they
decide to go to New York so it's just
kind of pointless with them being here
what the ultimates have done is they've
constructed a plan specifically they
need Kitty Pride more so than anything
else and so once Kitty pride is brought
to the ultimate they reveal the nature
of their plant that because Kitty Pride
can become intangible she can phase
through solid objects what they're gonna
do is they're going to give her pen
particles and that in turn is going to
allow her to grow to a gigantic size to
meet Galactus in terms of his physical
presence and then given the nature of
her ability to basically phase in and
out of things because her powers disrupt
whatever it is she phases in and out of
she's going to basically one part combat
Galactus to the best of her ability and
then two she's gonna phase through the
various uh I guess the kind of the world
engine and disrupt it this is an act of
desperation in the main Marvel Universe
this would never happen Kitty Pride
would never be grown to a gigantic size
so she can fight Galactus because she
would never win but I mean that's one of
the things I imagine people are looking
at this and they're like this is
preposterous no way she would stand a
chance against that guy and you're right
but the other part of this plan is to
use the power of Jean Gray to scan the
mind of Galactus and at the very least
get a better understanding of what's
going on here now with her telepathy she
realizes that Galactus is hungry that
he's desperate that he's not sure he has
the strength to finish building his
machine that he still is not entirely
sure where he is he knows that there's
an earth that this is this is a Earth
but it's not in his own Dimension and he
doesn't know how he got here or if he
can even get back and so what she starts
to realize is that Galactus consuming
the Earth is just a stopgap measure this
is just him basically eating before he
kind of sits down and figures out okay
now that I'm satiated how do I get back
home do I use all my power to try to
open a portal will it even work that way
when I use my powers to try to open a
portal back home can I Traverse the
Multiverse in that capacity if him just
basically eating so he can think long
enough to figure out what to do and so
of course with with galatus realizing
that uh that Jean Gray is reading his
mind he immediately forces her out this
leads to them basically launching an
attack which includes ultimate Thor you
know kind of distracting Galactus as
best they can by just firing off massive
weapons and and so on and so forth and
so where Galactus is able to hold his
own or at least you know not really too
stressed about these guys it allows them
to initiate their plan with one Captain
America stepping in piloting a vessel
and then trying to attack Galactus he
literally like flies into Galactus flies
into his mouth and then is presumably
left for dead right like supposedly he
like runs to the exit and tries to jump
out but by all standards the measurement
it looks like he's basically dying the
ship of the ultimate is basically
destroyed this whole gigantic attack
this launched against Galactus to try to
like at least distract him or defeat him
none of it works and he just goes right
back to constructing his ship right goes
right back to constructing his world
eating machine and so with seemingly
everything else failed they initiate the
plan with Kitty prod she grows to this
gigantic size and then she goes to like
start phasing through Galactus Machinery
in order to try to disable it right in
order to try to you know short-circuit
it or whatever it is but basically end
it she does fight Galactus where she can
by just kind of taking these pot Shots
by like you know phasing her self into
into like a solid material punching him
and then making yourself intangible
again it's small little things but by
and large this effort that she has it's
only really just a small little
significant insignificant thing that
it's not designed to actually defeat him
that the real plan here with Kitty Pride
kind of operating as a distraction the
real plan here comes from Ultimate Reed
Richards that what he ends up doing is
literally constructing a Negative Zone
portal a portal that grants him access
to the negative Zone in Marvel Comics
you have the Multiverse right just an
infinite number of universes sometimes
these universes are different sometimes
they're the same in Marvel Comics you
only have one Negative Zone but every
Universe can access the Negative Zone
it's a realm of of literally anti-matter
and so there's no real way of knowing
whether or not Galactus could survive
there but at this point the
understanding of the negative zone for
ultimate Reed Richards is nowhere near
as good as it is with the main Marvel
Universe read right main Marvel Universe
read understands the Negative Zone much
better than Ultimate Universe read
Richards does and so in the midst of
this gigantic fight Dan end up opening
the portal which starts to suck Galactus
in the problem with this is that given
the power of Galactus he's actually able
to prevent himself from being sucked in
fully but only so much right I mean it's
literally a singularity that's been
opened here a gravity well that pulls
everything in the problem is Kitty
Prides being sucked in as well and so
what ends up happening here is that
ultimate Susan storm and Miles Morales
end up traveling literally to where
Kitty Prides at so that they can
basically try to find a way or at least
try to save her life and so what they
end up doing is they instruct Kitty
Pride right like on the count of three
shrink down to your normal size I will
web you up Susan's storm will fly us out
of here and will save you from The
Singularity on top of this where
Galactus is literally holding on for
dear life and seemingly like there's no
possible way to suck him into the
singularity ultimate Thor goes back on
the attack yet again and then hits
Galactus with his own with his hammer
and sends Galactus flying into the
Negative Zone portal of course Kitty
Pride saved and like Galactus is
effectively now stuck in the negative
Zone and so that's kind of the crazy
thing because in the midst of this
Thor's locked in there as well ultimate
Thor ends up being stuck in the negative
Zone and so for the most part with the
day sort of being saved I wouldn't go as
far as to say that they don't really
care about Thor or anything like that
but the story actually ends on a
cliffhanger leaving us wondering if like
Captain America actually died what will
happen with Galactus being stuck in the
negative Zone while Thor ultimate Thor
ever end up making his way out it was a
story designed to kind of springboard
into several other stories in Ultimate
Comics but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end let me
know what you think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace